arianna can you just say your name where
you're from okay
wait where I'm from isn't like finding
yes yes hi my name is Arianna rates and
I'm from Fandango hi Andy hi Selena what
is it like working in a sound booth I
think you can both answer that question
it's wonderful I mean Slee and I both
have equally successful music careers so
we've had a lot of experience in the
reporting you've had a lot of recording
booth experience so coming into this we
definitely I think for you say we were
prepared for the experience on your own
fireworks on the cruise it's not The
Love Boat rank you must be the one and
only Dracula hey do BD Shula a cou BB
what is it like to play oh it is so
satisfying to play the bill that I've
never really had a chance to and I love
it so much especially a villain like
this because it's like you don't really
know that she is for a while yeah you
were right great-grandfather van Helsing
monsters are disgusting when you uh when
you finish the movie and you watch it
after it's done do you find your voice
is sounding like different or we're
coming from maybe Johnny's mouth I hate
hearing my voice sometimes speaking it's
just weird I think you have a lovely
voice I think you have a great voice too
thanks well mine's very loud that's the
one characteristic I would say
especially when I'm playing Johnny the
loudness is very similar almost
unprecedented yeah so that to me can be
a bit jarring but I did it so I got us
sleep in the bed I make you know there
is something about that woman I don't
trust
the food here is to die for
must have been garlic in the guacamole
and non-animated film or like an
animated film oh I would say a
non-native animated film for sure this
is so fun because you couldn't just roll
out of bed and show up to work it makes
it really easy yeah which one you like
better I don't know they're both really
fun this is I this is was really fun
because I'm a mom I have two little kids
and so I'm really excited that they get
to go see something that I've done too
so I'm really excited to share this with
them they love Hotel Transylvania movies
so that they were I feel like I've
gotten some some street cred with them
[Music]
we know that Erika does not like
monsters so um whoa how would you feel
if you came on contact with the monster
oh well you know I feel like I might be
scared at first just because of what I
think I know about monsters but then it
depends on with them who the monster is
you know hopefully if we have a good
conversation like Erika I might be able
to change my my mind on what I think
monsters are so I think that's what
happens with Erika come on there's so
much to do
you could go scuba diving try some
exotic foods
or just enjoy the views okay guys thank
you for people who haven't seen like the
first or second movie what do you think
they'd like and understand about this
one I think it's fun I think also we
have a great message so all these things
that art they tend to be scary to kids
like monsters we make light of them and
show them as bridges regular families
that are going through the same things
yeah it's fun mm-hmm what about you Sam
I mean I think the the comedy of it
translates to anyone of any age and I
think the characters especially the
monsters are very iconic so they're
universally known by people and you fall
into step with that very quickly
oh no Blondie's gonna puke
[Music]
[Music]
you